hey guys i'm ryan right hello and i'm
ryan shoes ryan shoes from the gallows
is here one of the form for sarge right
the four of us yeah one of the four main
stars the gallows we're here today we're
gonna check out from dark five I figure
gallows horror film five scariest things
really found hiding under people's beds
I told him I wouldn't do this but then I
said you know what I'm gonna sacrifice
my sleep for tonight yeah man it's
totally worth it up he freaks me out so
much yeah it's funny think it's funny
cuz he he's a star Oh horror movie but
buddy but he doesn't really like dealing
with horror and stuff if I see an infant
under a bed I'm people are gonna watch
your reaction so don't don't don't turn
away I'm watching you and unidentified C
sneer when I'm watching you
greevey
although deep is I please rest assured
only modo she got the feet
really unnerving man the music inside
come on
Wow that's it
well there's dots Oh oh my god how
horrified it's a good thing I can read
yeah I didn't know it's got to read the
stuff that's don't do that don't get
girls that way guy well rush back to his
room if many lodges Bob late afternoon
to the house it was there they [ __ ]
with long 300-pound now crocodile
thrashing under the bed whoa that's just
it's just cool yeah to remain from
monster and shermaine mullahs are out of
hope we don't slip right on top of in
the night before oh my god scary just
centimetres away from the croc
Wow really found it right under grinder
your big I did I don't know any of those
numbers me it sounds bad one of the most
powerful 5000 won psi into the abyss Jeb
Bush was heard screaming for help in a 7
or Florida I'm falling into a massive ah
unfortunate situation first was jumping
in the water
I got your brother
or something there it was just about one
of those sinkholes
oh that's Oh No
Beck I'm in a lot of attractions in this
[ __ ]
oh my god really
would he heard a voice he's thought he
heard his brother there was nothing the
guy was dead James and Rhonda sergeants
remember two days
oh my god
lesson
Oh
no one check its cleaning Lee Suk oh
here we go number one method she did
they take the batteries the batteries
ambitious
I D sneered pollution on the door
handles
was it
come on don't show that picture
I didn't like that last one
didn't even give like a real is just
like lotion on the matter there she was
yeah with a knife and she's 90 pounds
what happened
no one knows oh my god 90 pounds that
sounds scary that last one got my
stomach
oh dude these are really not cool a
stalker I know it's like to have a
stalker it's not me dude
I come on man just admit it
do you really well I know it's like to
stalk someone I think I got Veronica she
was into it he was persistent yeah she
was really into it after 12 years I
always I always am a guide like go to a
party and I'll always like take some
hand lotion i smeared on all our
doorknobs ah yeah I do that what might
come to just fun yeah you know Oh what's
going on yeah
like mm-hmm meth addict here and it
seems like the acts of a meth addict
I'm glad Veronica like was into your
stocking though yeah she's into like
crazy [ __ ] you lucked out yeah knives
and you know this other girl she was so
uptight like come on a few text messages
he's 18 it's legal it was consent it was
consent there's love and stalking love
clearly
all right the sinkhole one was just like
that's not finding something under your
bed your house yeah yeah how it's so
weird that sucks so much like the
comfort of your own home good putt
what where duck sucks so much cycle
suckle suckle suck hole you know you're
saying right you're so you're saying
suck hole I know this is not this you're
you're making it sound like you're
talking about the house going in but I'm
trying to tell you it's it sounds like
something else yeah I got you I'm right
there with you do you wanna I feel weird
connecting with you in the eyes when you
tell me about this suckle those the
crocodile crocodile one
300 pound thrashing crocodile [ __ ] I
don't even get in there
it said traveled a mile and a half I'm
recalling all these facts hey Justin the
decided adventure into this omen and I
believe it was a 5000 psi if I'm
recalling correctly no that sounds so
[ __ ] creepy man crocodiles freak me
out
they do I love how they refer to it as a
monster no yeah for sure
yeah that's what they call him at the
zoo if you look to the right you'll see
these monsters here no dude I would
never [ __ ] with a croc I never [ __ ] a
croc
oh maybe depends what Veronica wants and
watch me get Wow he's so cold so cold
the one with the woman under the motel
bed for like three weeks that cleaning
staff needs to be fired
yeah unless Lee why no one bother to
check like like then it smells like it
when we're at the bed nah can't be under
the bed
that's so it's like does none of these
people have common sense like it's
around here the bed area and I bet you
those cleaning ladies were getting
tipped I know right good money good
money like they were hard-working
Mexican woman who got tipped really good
money to not look under the bed not look
under the bed yeah yeah yeah people must
have notice and must have them until not
like I I just fight a total [ __ ] to
like [ __ ] not look under the bed for
a second beauty there's an odor you
can't discover we just call it [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] if busted it by our
theories of how stupid people are you
couldn't be all right
this last picture right here of the way
that lady that was by that was DAB's
[ __ ] up yeah they didn't need to show
up it looked like her eyes were like
torn out of her sockets do you think
that this picture they did was like a
tell me the couple took this picture you
know like most people that believes
you've attracted everything into your
life on one of those people but
sometimes I hear stories like this some
like there's no way you attracted a
90-pound meth lady into your home with a
knife there's no way you thought of it I
get rockin out I haven't eaten picture
it's making me really uncomfortable
I understand just okay just picture this
so you go into bed
you kiss each other and this lady you do
that zoom down right and the lashes is
sitting there with a knife on her over
chest ninety pounds not eating she's
been there for two days after just
having smeared lotion all over every one
of your doorknobs and thrown your mail
around I would've loved to have sex with
Veronica on top of that bed a 90-pound
Madeleine [ __ ] dude I totally thought
you're gonna say you would have sex with
the 90-pound you're like no come on up
here I feel like I break her oh yeah
masak dick
jibanyan Colin
well anyway guys that's it for today
thanks for suggesting that well yeah you
guys are really nice and sweet if you're
new to the channel you can subscribe to
the real rejects Ryan stars and the
gallows comes out October 13th on DVD
and blu-ray keep a look out for that and
keep a look out for the vlog I'll be
doing at the haunted mansion based off
the gallows and frere was filmed where
it was filmed this is like the one of
the most haunted places in California is
where we filmed it and you follow us on
Facebook Instagram Twitter and vine and
I have a periscope I have one more than
you I don't have that one
Jael Joe hi Ryan can I get a shoutout
thank you very much oh love your channel
it's entertainment funny your guests
like your wife Veronica she's not oh god
I look about that
Brandi Sally and many more funny great
so keep up the good work
Thanks dank je way sheets greets from
the Netherlands City Deventer hold on
hold on
how's he doing
it's Brianna this is uh Ryan when the
stars the galas nice to meet you have
you heard of the gallows come on yeah
you can't believe it jail Joe um thanks
for saying we're really funny
thanks for saying we're entertaining you
have no photos of yourself you strike me
as one of the people who will one day be
talked about in one of these videos that
we just saw he was found with a bottle
of beer hiding in your yeah you can't
trust someone who doesn't have photos on
their Facebook
I just can't smelled so weird in my room
for so long yeah but I didn't check the
closet there were feces left in the
toilet police couldn't identify you and
what you douche bag jail yeah these are
the leftover checkers insult the
subscribers that's how shoutouts go take
care I'll take care